[Music]
it's a royal double date at Grandma's I
think it's for this pretty impressive
newly engaged Prince Harry and Megan
Markel joined Prince William and Kate
Middleton for Queen Elizabeth's annual
pre Christmas lunch at Buckingham Palace
on Wednesday because I'm from the States
you don't grow up with the same
understanding of the royal family Megan
took part in her very first royal
tradition with over 50 royal family
members including Princess Eugenie
princess Patrice Prince Charles and his
wife Camilla this is assumed to be the
first time the suit star has met most of
the extended royal family before Harry
and his bride-to-be tie the knot at
Windsor Castle on May 19th
2018 the family loves Windsor Castle
there's room for the pomp and ceremony
that people associate with royal
weddings the palace confirms the et
Meghan is the first fiance to spend the
holidays with the Royals at the Queen's
Country Estate
Sandringham this is a big change in
protocol typically an unmarried couple
can't spend Christmas with the British
royal family
you
[Music]